hello to you I'm GAD I'm Dan we're the
slow mo guys as you can see I'm wearing
my dangerous outfit again got everything
this time when Dan's were in the blue
suit you know it's gonna be a good one
that's gonna go down I'm very fascinated
by aerosol cans and the fact that
there's liquid in their pressurized and
as soon as the pressure is released it
just vaporised we did it with the
deodorant can a long time ago and I want
to do it with paint yeah we've got lots
of different colored spray paint behind
me there as you can see so I'm gonna
take an axe and a sledgehammer to them
and see if we can get some different
effects yeah but basically to make some
spray paint art without once using the
nozzle of the spray how can we get it
out of there without using the correct
method of getting out of there feel free
to send us your methods of getting spray
paint out of the can without spraying it
but don't do it with an axe or a
sledgehammer because it's dangerous but
be safe yes ending your answers on a
postcard so I think we'll start we'll
start with some green and before we move
on to axe and sledge let's do a BB gun
oh yeah
I can't believe that it didn't go
anywhere and only painted the background
yeah we couldn't have done that if we
tried okay all right let's try again
with red so if you can glance it and
maybe get it to spin through there it on
the side and
so the glance was definitely different
spun it completely I mean I want we
didn't put a tarp down on the garden
obviously no I mean we the green one I
thought just you know okay whatever but
the blue we hit on the side they just
went absolutely mental we should have
done that with the green room cuz then
it would have just painted the grass
green war Oh perhaps you could do green
now just reap that repai dear yeah as
you can see the entrance wound is at the
side and it's angled and that's why this
time it's pan around where's the exit
all right stays in there oh really
yeah it doesn't make it out well they
come with like a little shaky ball
bearing in there don't they so now it's
gone
that's to now yeah that's coming along
nicely it's a bit of a is it called a a
wibble what's the thing in the middle
call and the wee little a wakil I think
so that's what you wear around your
tying Cubs in Cubs
yeah like Cub Scouts pretty sure a
boggle the nog Googler something is I
think it might be a nog gobbler yeah a
veg gondola you get them in beer as well
blah fogger
fob or glue how am I ever gonna sell
this place
you have to wait for it to grow out and
mow over it alright I think that's some
good good work on the distance once yeah
absolutely you're gonna get up close and
personal maybe the axe
I think I'm ready I've got like a kit
and equipment
good I was not expecting more I was nice
but I know is just Mexican army
okay sledge Rooney yeah
our Universal genre inside then all the
beans B that was wicked
then we've got enough sledge how about a
lengthways ax-cut so you want me to hit
it like this down the length of it we
can like that yeah I mean honestly this
is just experimentation this point no
idea if it'll look different or anything
but do you like that you know that's
like an area there or it's like so
layered yeah the backgrounds getting
really soggy is it yeah that's to dry
out
remember that really nice layering I was
just talking about yeah all gone bloody
all under the grip I think our painting
is almost complete
we just need sort of maybe a multicolor
yeah okay well like for like a few min
one why do you sound so terrible it's
got a cold okay grand finale like
sprayed on my feet no sparkly oh wow
let's send us some of that weight on
your face - I know Anna's gonna say and
my face every time it's my ankles with
hands on my face nothing else gets it
that's all though we've got some well
nice new patterns on this Oh sick look
at these this is uncopyable this it's
copyable but it would take you some
sweet reference in time let's make the
final touches to this painting there we
go
we've ruined your background basically
but he was dangerous and messy the
roughing it was worth in your voices
shot yeah like most of our workmates
smeary and not symmetrical I got high
you got high and some paint fumes
yeah like nice video his bits of label
wood grass this is shoddy you make we
went through a lot of speech we did I
think this this one's knackered we
should pull onto this this one I think
would be a nice piece of art so we'll
slop it on eBay for a week and donate
the proceeds to extra life charity
if you feel interested in having this
well this absolute masterpiece tonight
don't rush it though we're not going to
donate to the danglers your fun days off
them is this a terrible cherry hopefully
you enjoyed that video free to subscribe
to the channel the second channel
Twitter in there buy a shirt bid on some
art there's a lot for you to think about
right now or just turn it off go
elsewhere go about your day don't do
that freedom freedom of the internet see
you next time